[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Brian Holt: Big O,
chúng tôi nói về điều này đầu tiên vì chúng tôi tham khảo lại trong toàn bộ khóa học.
Và Big O là cách mà chúng ta phân tích mức độ hiệu quả của một thuật toán.
Và đó là một khái niệm toán học mà chúng tôi vay mượn từ khoa học máy tính,
bởi vì nó thực sự hữu ích cho chúng tôi.
Và tôi nghĩ bạn sẽ thấy rất nhiều điều đó ngày hôm nay, toán học và
khoa học máy tính rõ ràng có rất nhiều chéo.
Nhưng đặc biệt khi áp dụng cho các thuật toán,
đã điều khiển tất cả điều này từ toán học đúng.
Điều đó có nghĩa là mặc dù đây là loại đá quý nhất mà chúng ta có được ngày hôm nay,
vì vậy không có dẫn xuất.
Không có tích phân.
Đây chỉ có thể là đại số hai-ish, có thể là đại số một.
Dù sao thì Ô lớn.
Vì vậy, chữ O lớn đang nói về bức tranh lớn, đó là những nét vẽ rộng.
Nó không phải là chi tiết, phải không?
Ví dụ,
nếu chúng ta có một thuật toán mất 300 mili giây so với 330 mili giây,
chúng ta không thực sự ở trong trường hợp cụ thể này, chúng ta không thực sự quan tâm lắm, phải không?
Vì chúng nằm trong phạm vi sai số, độ lệch chuẩn phải không?
Chúng tôi thậm chí không thực sự quan tâm nhiều đến vậy nếu nó là 300 so với 500
mili giây, phải không?
Điều chúng tôi thực sự quan tâm hơn nhiều là 300 mili giây hoặc
là 30 giây.
Chúng tôi đang quan tâm đến các thứ tự chênh lệch kiểu cường độ.
Vì vậy, đó là những gì Big O làm, về cơ bản nó cho phép chúng tôi hút đi tất cả
những chi tiết nhỏ, tất cả các chi tiết, và chỉ cần nhìn vào bức tranh thực sự lớn ở đây.
Vì vậy, tôi thích nghĩ về chữ O lớn giống như một chiếc máy hút bụi lớn chỉ hút
tất cả các thông tin ít quan trọng hơn từ nó.
Vì vậy, một lần nữa, đây là phép toán lớn nhất mà chúng ta sẽ nhận được ngày hôm nay.
Chỉ cần tưởng tượng phương trình này 3x bình phương + x + 1, đúng.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn cắm như mười ở đó, phải không.
Bạn sẽ nhận được 10 bình phương, 100,
300 cộng với 10, 310, 311.
Chúng tôi sẽ chỉ sử dụng phép toán mà tôi đã có ở đó, vì vậy
Tôi không cần phải làm toán trong đầu.
75, nếu bạn cắm 5, 5 cộng với 1, vì vậy
bạn sẽ thích 81, xin lỗi, [COUGH].
Nhưng ngay sau khi chúng tôi bắt đầu kết hợp số lượng lớn ở đây,
chúng ta sẽ nhận được những con số rõ ràng là rất lớn, phải không?
Vì vậy, đó sẽ là hàng triệu, hàng tỷ, hàng nghìn tỷ.
75 nghìn tỷ nếu chúng ta đầu tư vào năm triệu.
Cái thứ hai sẽ là năm triệu và cái cuối cùng sẽ là một.
Tất cả những điều này để nói rằng chúng tôi đang chứng minh ở đây là x bình phương này thực sự là
thực sự phần lớn giá trị đến từ đâu trong phương trình này, đúng không.
Đến mức về cơ bản chúng ta có thể bỏ qua những gì đang xảy ra
ở đây bởi vì chúng chỉ là nhấp nháy, hoặc
chúng là một sự sụt giảm trong số lượng lớn các con số đến từ đây.
Vì vậy, đây là những gì O lớn làm, về cơ bản nó nói rằng tôi sẽ tiếp tục và
bỏ qua những thứ đó vì nó sẽ không thực sự ảnh hưởng nhiều đến những gì tôi
sẽ làm ở đây. >> Sinh viên: [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC]
>> Brian Holt: Vâng.
>> Brian Holt: Vậy đó là chữ O lớn
sẽ làm.
Về cơ bản, nó sẽ cho phép chúng ta bỏ qua những phần nhỏ hơn này của phương trình.
Vì vậy, O lớn của phương trình này sẽ là
O n bình phương bởi vì chúng tôi thực sự sẽ bỏ qua 3.
Chúng ta thậm chí không thực sự quan tâm đến các hệ số, phải không?
Như tôi đã nói, chúng tôi không quan tâm đó là 300 mili giây hay 600 mili giây.
Chúng tôi quan tâm nếu đó là 30 giây so với 300 mili giây.
Vì vậy, đó là những gì O lớn sẽ làm cho chúng ta và đó thực sự chỉ là nó.
Về cơ bản, bạn sẽ tìm kiếm thuật ngữ lớn nhất là thứ có
số mũ lớn nhất và nói, được rồi, đó là chữ O lớn, đúng.
Đó thực chất là những gì đang diễn ra ở đây. >> Brian Holt: Vì vậy
O lớn chỉ là hấp thụ tất cả các lông tơ khác.
Về cơ bản, nó chỉ là số mũ lớn nhất.
Bây giờ có nhiều cách hơn mà O lớn làm được nếu bạn đi vào toán học, nhưng
chúng tôi không quan tâm, ít nhất là không phải hôm nay. >> Brian Holt: Và
phần lớn, chúng ta sẽ nói về vấn đề này về mặt thời gian.
Vì vậy, 600 mili giây so với 60 giây, nhưng bạn cũng có thể sử dụng điều này cho
phân tích không gian.
Vì vậy, nếu một thuật toán phải chiếm nhiều bộ nhớ hơn,
bạn cũng có thể sử dụng O lớn để phân tích như thế này.
Nếu tôi sắp xếp mảng này, nó sẽ chiếm nhiều gấp bốn lần
không gian để có thể sắp xếp mọi thứ một cách chính xác, bạn cũng có thể sử dụng nó để
kiểu phân tích không gian đó.
Và chúng tôi sẽ đề cập đến vấn đề đó, nhưng chúng tôi sẽ không tập trung vào nó.